well an endangered species is a beast
considered highly likely to become
extinct in the near future fending
increasingly for themselves they're put
at risk for the loss of territory their
plight is made worse by ruthless
poachers who often want to bring them
down as a trophy to their own prowess
sadly these big beasts sometimes too
deluded to realize that it's already
over it's only the poor marksmanship of
the hapless hunters that spares them
their futures
stanley johnson is here you're not
talking apology
[Laughter]
stanley i'm obviously talking uh trophy
hunting and endangered species no let's
start first of all i sense the trap it's
not a trap uh let's just be completely
upfront about this talking of endangered
species uh who may be facing
possible end your sun boris
i have to ask you about it because he
won't come on the show i'm going to
interview him in seven years
now let's talk if i'm right about
endangered species well we will well let
us talk about boris first all right then
we'll come to the trophy here and your
book
i'm just curious you're his dad right
he's been through one hell of a
period in his life
he becomes prime minister he gets brexit
done he's then hit by a global pandemic
he's hit by a war in ukraine uh he's hit
by all sorts of stuff surging inflation
now in the middle of it he gets covered
and nearly dies his mother dies
you put all this together that's a hell
of a two and a half years for any human
being
as his father when you've watched him
go through all this what have you been
thinking i've been thinking i am very
proud of this boy of this man
over this pm i mean that's what i say to
myself
i mean he caught you know the big calls
right as well like i'm saying he's got a
lot of things right you know okay i'm an
environmentalist i think the way he
pushed on climate change the way he
pushed on biodiversity the way he pushed
if we get to it
so this is
endangered species yeah it's fine and
honestly you know if you ask me my
absolute opinion on this i'd say i'd say
i
i listen to what you have what imran
khan said to you the other day you know
people in in karachi
but bewildered at the attention which
this this partygate beer gate order but
you know why it's had it's it's rattled
people the party gay is not really about
parties right you and i have been to a
lot of parties together right it's all
about it's not about the parties it's
about the at the time when he and his
government were locking people in their
homes and they couldn't go and see dying
relatives who were literally dying in
hospital from covid that was the rule
the law when the queen was at her own
husband's funeral sitting on her own
because she wanted to abide by the
letter of the law
there is boris the prime minister being
fined by the police for breaking his own
law and 84 of his staff
fined for illegal party so that's the
scandal no well i don't actually see it
in that in that way because i see it
something that happened on the 19th of
on the 19th of june 2020 which was just
a few weeks after he came out of out of
hospital having been really seriously
ill he steps by for for 20 minutes
it's his birthday he comes a birthday
party he broke his own laws down yeah
come on come on pierce we're not done
take my word for it take the police's
word for it okay
i think that
that
is time is time to move on from that you
know
it was a situation where
yes
he has a drink
he put this had a glass in his hand
and that was it that was the end of it
yeah it's all about the drink is it it's
about having a party which breaks his
own hand he hates when he was telling
other people every day from the podium
you can't do this it's the doing one
thing and preaching another no you know
that look i know you're in charge of
this interview and no reason why you
shouldn't because you know you're the
you're the big cheese but i didn't come
here you know that's all i'm concerned
it's high time we moved on to things
which really matter which are the things
he is doing now do you see it's the
things he's doing
and you mentioned them you know kevin
let's hope that's out of the way
inflation he's got to deal with it
ukraine ukraine
well who is taking the lead on ukraine i
think he's been good on ukraine yeah i
do i think boris has been i think he's
been a leader on ukraine and on the big
calls on kobe i think he got some right
and some horribly wrong first half of it
he was a complete disaster the second
half i thought with the vaccine program
rolled out and not locking down actually
at the end of the last year i think
there were two important calls he got
right
britain feels a much freer country right
now
then if you go abroad so i think he's
got some of the goals right but the idea
he's got all the big calls right well i
think it's a bit ridiculous right i
don't think i said that i think he he's
i think he's got you know
many of the big calls right and that's
that i think is crucial and you know as
far as i'm concerned i am because you
asked me the question i am particularly
pleased to see this son of mine
being prime minister whether other sons
would be brightness or another matter
but i am very very pleased about this
and long may he
lost when you see him being
attacked repeatedly for being dishonest
for being amoral all those things what
do you feel about you know him better
than most people yeah this is what i
feel i feel this is a lot of garbage i
mean total garbage i see this as the
worst kind of journalism i'm not going
to name the journalists i hope i don't
have to meet them but honestly i think
it's and i think it's tinged with look
it's a hunting scene isn't it we're
going to get on to him we're all going
to go
it's a hunting scene there we are they
think the beast is wounded let's scale
up after him let's fire a shoot few more
shots it is it is absurd we have to move
is he irreparably wounded by the fact
that 42
of conservative mps don't have
confidence in him no i don't think in
some country if you look at the figures
more conservative mps voted in a
confidence vote for boris johnson than
have ever voted for it for a
conservative prime minister in any
confidence vote look at the figures no
it may be that's because there were more
conservative mps to vote that's why okay
that's why but why were there more
conservative mps it was because
that doesn't work leave the percentage
out of it leave the sheer numbers the
percentage is all that matters isn't
that sheer numbers got that result and
you cannot deny that the the 368 tory
mps who were elected in
2019 were elected you know
you're a sharp political animal you know
that actually
the stats are now heavily against him
hardly any conservative prime minister
has ever survived much longer than six
months from a no-confidence vote even if
they they all win them but the margin of
the win is what brings them down hey let
me tell you something i am completely
confident that
at this time two years from now you and
i will be having this conversation
possibly and you will be saying well
you're still the father of prime
minister of institute you know what you
that might be true i'm not saying
necessarily that should be what happens
but i think you might be right he has
got the escapology skills of harry
houdini hasn't he
eugenie as i recall eventually died
because someone he did
struck him in the tummy rather i'm not
mentioning jeremy hunt but you know
you've got to be careful who's around
him at the moment um
look
we need to concentrate on the main
things as far as i'm concerned why i'm
here tonight is there's a crucial moment
when this government and i'm not
criticizing my prime minister i'm not
doing that but nonetheless just to show
i am not as it were starry-eyed i am
deeply worried that the proposal the
government
um has promised to make regarding
banning trophy hunting imports has not
yet seen the light of day well let's be
clear about that because i agree with
you about trophy hunting i think it's a
disgusting thing and it shouldn't be
allowed to happen boris said he was
going to get rid of it and he hasn't so
he's gone back on his word
well it's to you no stanford
the word is the word as it appeared in
the conservative party manifesto and if
you ask the government about it the
government
asked
says
firmly
you talked to him privately about it i
don't go into what i say privately to my
son and i wouldn't expect him to say
what he says to me you know on there but
nonetheless on this sort of thing i
would prefer to speak out loud to you
peers in the privacy of this studio yes
if you see what i mean the government
has to move on this because i don't want
to say for those who haven't followed
the this whole saga what is it exactly
you and a lot of signatories to a letter
want to get
what done okay
trophy hunting is still
massively practiced all around the world
and by the way british sportsmen are
massively involved in trophy hunting and
we have a time when endangered species
aren't truly endangered and we've got
the animals we've got
lions and rhinos and they're wrong i
agree they're all all there and yet
people are still getting prizes from the
safari club international you know for
killing 100 different species of animals
people are paying 50 thousand dollars to
fly in from america from minnesota we
saw the cecil reliance absolutely so i
want the government to really deliver on
its promise to bring in this law
banning the import of of trophies and
also i want the government to push hard
now on this other thing which is again
in the manifesto which is to do with
animals abroad and the fact that british
tourists
are going off in huge numbers postcoded
to places like thailand and india and
other places where animals are abused
for spectacles and entertainment
particularly you've reached a point of
agreement although i would point out on
trade behind today yeah look at this
it's also a prime example of your of
your son saying one thing and not doing
it
no he is
got every chance to do it that is the
point he's watching this program what's
your message to him about trophy home
sorry watch his watches every day he
ever comes on it well i can't get out of
the fridge
i can't speak to that but
i am convinced that environment remains
a top priority of this government
climate change maintenance for top
priority biodiversity marines and animal
species okay
is there you've got a great new book out
from an antique land you've written how
many books are this is my 25th
unbelievable where did you get the
energy you johnson's no i don't have any
injuries
relentless isn't that that's a very nice
thing to say that is a thriller that is
a thriller and it's all to do with what
happened in cambodia in 1975. i look
forward to reading it i like all your
books the i wanted to show you a bit of
footage this is of a [ __ ] a cockerel in
turkey this is the moment stanley where
i think you and i probably boris as well
have a moment don't we occasionally when
you just want to do this watch this
[Applause]
i'm sure that's not the call
[Laughter]
it's not the famous johnson meeting i
think it could be the caller than where
it's in it comes from turkey
watch the end though stan you see what
happens at the end here
it's going it's going now the last time
the last time i saw a magnificent beast
like that doing something similar was
when you came on good morning britain
and we got to do a handstand remember
this come on
i don't remember it's really sensible
again again no that's it
i've got i've got it
i failed to say it then i'm happy to say
it now stanley it's great to see you as
always effervescent presence and you are
a cheater i've got to tell you pierce
you know you lured me in here it was a
bit like cecil the lion
i'm a trophy hunter i learned him
i don't think i'm a trophy
there's something wrong with defending
your son by the way and we got to talk
about trophy hunting and your book and i
showed you doing a handstand the world's
looking for stanley oh thank you peers
good to see you
see you all folks
tell boris to come in soon we'd have fun
cheers dally good to see you
i think he's going to get boris out of
the fridge to get him on the show